- [Voiceover] Let F be
a continuous function
on the closed interval
from negative two to one
where F of negative two is equal to three
and F of one is equal to six.
Which of the following is guaranteed
by the Intermediate Value Theorem?
So before I even look at this,
what do we know about the
Intermediate Value Theorem?
Well it applies here,
it's a continuous function
on this closed interval.
We know what the value of the
function is at negative two.
It's three so let me write that.
F of negative two is equal to three
and F of one, they tell
us right over here,
is equal to six
and all the Intermediate
Value Theorem tells us
and if this is completely
unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to watch the video
on the Intermediate Value Theorem,
is that if we have a continuous function
on some closed interval,
then the function must take on every value
between the values at the
endpoints of the interval
or another way to say it is
for any L
between three and six,
three and six,
there is at least one C,
one C,
between, or I could say
once C in the interval
from negative two to
one, the closed interval,
such that F of C is equal to L.
This comes straight out of
the Intermediate Value Theorem
and just saying it in everyday language
is look this is a continuous function.
Actually I'll draw it
visually in a few seconds.
But it makes sense that
if it's continuous,
if I were to draw the graph,
I can't pick up my pencil,
well that it makes sense
that I would have to
take on every value between three and six
or there's at least one
point in this interval
where I take on any given
value between three and six.
So let's see which of these
answers are consistent with that
and we only pick one.
So F of C equals four.
So that would be a case
where L is equal to four.
So there's at least one C
in this interval such that
F of C is equal to four.
We could say that.
But that's not exactly
what they're saying here.
F of C could be four for at least one C,
not in this interval,
remember the C is our X.
This is our X right over here.
So the C is going to be in this interval
and I'll take a look at
it visually in a second
so that we can validate that.
We're not saying for at least one C
between three and six F
of C is equal to four,
we're saying for at least
one C in this interval
F of C is going to be equal to four.
It's important that four
is between three and six
because that's the value of our function
and the C needs to be
in our closed interval
along the x-axis.
So I'm gonna rule this out.
They're trying to confuse us.
Alright.
F of C equals zero for at least one C
between negative two and one.
Well here they got the interval
along the x-axis right,
that's where the C would be between,
but it's not guaranteed by
the Intermediate Value Theorem
that F of C is going to be equal to zero
because zero is not between three and six.
So I'm gonna rule that one out.
I'm going to rule this one out,
it's saying F of C equals zero,
and let's see, we're
only left with this one
so I hope it works.
So F of C is equal to four,
well that seems reasonable because
four is between three and six,
for at least one C between
negative two and one.
Well yeah because that's in
this interval right over here.
So I am feeling good about that
and we could think about
this visually as well.
The Intermediate Value Theorem
when you think about it
visually makes a lot of sense.
So let me draw the x-axis first actually
and then let me draw my y-axis
and I'm gonna draw them
at different scales
'cause my y-axis, well let's see.
If this is six, this is three.
That's my y-axis.
This is one, this is negative one,
this is negative two
and so we're continuous
on the closed interval
from negative two to one
and F of negative two is equal to three.
So let me plot that.
F of negative two is equal to three.
So that's right over there
and F of one is equal to six.
and so let's try to draw
a continuous function.
So a continuous function
includes these points
and it's continuous so an
intuitive way to think about it
is I can't pick up my
pencil if I'm drawing
the graph of the function,
which contains these two points.
So I can't do that.
That would be picking up my pencil.
So it is a continuous function.
So it takes on every value.
As we can see, it definitely does that.
It takes on every value
between three and six.
It might take on other
values, but we know for sure
it has to take on every
value between three and six
and so if we think about
four, four is right over here.
The way I drew it, it looks
like it's almost taking on
that value right at the y-axis.
I forgot to label my x-axis here.
But you can see it took on that value
in for a C in this case
between negative two and one
and I could have drawn that
graph multiple different ways.
I could have drawn it something
like I could have done it
and actually it takes on,
there's multiple times it
takes on the value four here.
So this could be our C, but once again
it's between the interval
negative two and one.
This could be our C once again
in the interval between
negative two and one
or this could be our C in between
the interval of negative two and one
and that's just the way
I happen to draw it.
I could have drawn this thing
as just a straight line.
I could have drawn it like this
and then it looks like
it's taking on for only one
and it's doing it right around there.
This isn't necessarily
true that you take on,
that you become four for at least one C
between three and six.
Three and six aren't
even on our graph here.
I would have to go all
the way to two, three.
There's not guarantee that
our function takes on four
for one C between three and six.
We don't even know what the function does
when X is between three and six.